is that this was a horribly intractable
problem but he took him on anyway
and
kendra went on
to work on myoglobin
and ended up
solving the first atomic structure of
any protein
for which he shared the nobel prize in
1962
with max
but to do that he had to introduce many
novel ideas at the time and certainly
ideas that were unfamiliar
to people in biochemistry or biophysics
for example he was one of the first
people to introduce digital computing
in crystallography and
he used edsac
which was a big mainframe computer in
cambridge to do all the fourier
synthesis
whereas previously it had been done
laboriously by hand
he also investigated multiple species
so he tried a lot of different species
of myoglobin before he hit on sperm
whale
because it produced good crystals and
even after the structure he was a
pioneer in comparing
sequences
from different species so in both
computing and in bioinformatics kendrew
uh was sort of ahead of his uh time
and finally he was a superb science
leader and organizer he helped found
ambo and embl he was the first director
of embl
he founded and was the editor for many
years of the journal of molecular
biology
which was highly influential
independence
in those days and
he also served as president in his later
life of saint john's college in oxford
so it's fitting that
this year's
kendra lecture is given by two
scientists who've used computational
methods to deduce atomic structure of
proteins
for several decades the protein folding
problem has been thought of as one of
the grand challenges of molecular
biology but progress on it over several
decades has been
rather gradual
and the structural community was both
astonished and excited
a couple of years ago
when the group at deepmind used machine
learning to top the annual
calf structure prediction competition
by quite a significant margin
and this year they've greatly
expanded both the accuracy and the scope
of their uh structure prediction program
and so we're very delighted uh
it's a great pleasure to have
uh the two of the leaders in this effort
uh demis hassabes who
founded greek deepmind and indeed
thought of this and many other efforts
and john jumper who has played a lead
role in the
alpha fold effort
the first lecture will be given by demis
hasabis
who started off as something of a
prodigy he was a
uh chess master at the age of 13. he
finished his a levels when he was 15 or
16 years old
and decided that before going to
university he would take a break
and work on designing a number of
computer games
he then went on to
university in cambridge where he
graduated in computer science and after
his degree he continued to work on
designing new games including two of
which were nominated for bafta
and at some point he decided
uh perhaps that he didn't want to spend
the rest of his life designing games and
decided to get a phd in cognitive
neuroscience at ucl
working with eleanor mcguire
and
my guess he can tell us if this is true
or not is maybe he thought
perhaps understanding the brain more
deeply could inspire developments in a.i
around that time he also spent
some time at both mit and harvard
before
continuing as a henry welcome
postdoctoral fellow at
back at ucl
and
his work at ucl resulted in a number of
highly cited papers
including one showing the connection
between amnesia and the ability to
imagine new experiences that is a
connection between memory and
imagination
which was cited as one of the 10
breakthroughs of the year by
science magazine
in 2010 after his postdoc
he ignored a suggestion from a very
leading and prominent scientist to apply
for a welcome career development award
and decided to found a company deepmind
with two others
and this has turned out to be one of the
leading ai companies in the world today
it was acquired by alphabet
the parent company of google in 2014
but remains an autonomous unit within
the
conglomerate
there was a great deal of publicity a
few years ago when
they produced a program alphago
which was able to defeat
some of the top players in the world at
go
a game that was previously thought to be
too complex
for computers
he then
went on to lead an effort to create
alpha zero which was not trained on any
human games but simply taught the rules
of the game
and uh was effectively trained itself
and uh
he started to
play chess and go
and uh one other game which i've
forgotten
and
it turns out that this was even stronger
suggesting that maybe human games were
holding the program back
anyway
my impression is that games uh
he might have thought of games as a
great test bed to test ideas about
machine learning but his long-term focus
from my conversations has always been on
using ai
for real world problems including
both scientific and medical challenges
so uh it's great pleasure to now welcome
demis to talk about using ai to
accelerate scientific discovery
[Applause]
thanks thank you for that great
introduction
it's really wonderful to be here
uh always wonderful to be back in
cambridge but also to be in such a uh
auspicious and sort of the cathedral of
the molecular biology the lmb uh to be
talking about alpha fault so it's a
great pleasure and honor to be here
so i'm gonna discuss uh a little bit
about alpha fold and and how that came
to be and and about the program itself
um but before i do that i wanted to
discuss a little bit about um the
general ai that we work on that led up
to alpha fold uh and and the thought
process behind that so the title of my
lecture is using ai to accelerate
scientific discovery and for me as venky
alluded to this is the whole reason why
i spent my entire career working on ai
even when i was making those computer
games they were all computer games that
were based on simulation and ai at the
heart so even at the time when i was
working on those in the 90s computer
games was actually one of the best
places to push forward ai research
and uh that was one of the reasons i was
i was in that field
so at deepmind our our mission um has
always been to try and solve
intelligence and by that i mean
fundamentally understand it the nature
of intelligence and then try and
recreate that in an artificial construct
and then use it to advance science uh
for the benefit of humanity
now when we talk about building
artificial intelligence sometimes we
call it artificial general intelligence
to sort of
emphasize this notion of generality we
would like an ai system that out of the
box can work across a wide range of
tasks
and there's been traditionally two sorts
of approaches to building ai
the older approach i guess a more
traditional approach is you can kind of
put it under the rubric of expert
systems
and the idea here is that you kind of
program it with directly with the
solution so um
usually the team of programmers or
engineers has solved the problem then
they express it in terms of a set of
rules uh and then uh the system
effectively uh uh
executes that that set of rules
and the inspiration for these types of
expert systems is perhaps mathematics
and logic networks and logic systems and
maybe the most famous example of an
expert system was deep blue the program
that beat gary kasparov for chess
in the in the mid 90s
so that's expert systems on the other
hand you have learning systems
and the idea here is that
the system learns for itself
and it learns solutions from first
principles so directly from experience
or from trial and error
um and the other part of learning
systems is that they're supposed to
generalize to new situations and new
tasks and i think that's what makes them
so exciting is they can potentially
solve things that we as the programmers
or the system designers don't yet know
how to solve um so that's the kind of
the potential uh of of these kinds of
systems uh to help us in in our
endeavors and a lot of the inspiration
for some of these learning systems has
come from traditionally from
neuroscience systems neuroscience uh and
uh and also can be validated by looking
at how the brain works uh for example
with things like reinforcement learning
and at deepmind we work on the right
hand side on learning systems and in
fact the sort of revolution that's
happening in ai and the renaissance if
you want to call it uh of the last
decade or so has been due to the success
at scale of these kinds of learning
systems
so what is a learning system um i've
just got a little cartoon diagram here
of of how they work um here it's
particularly reinforcement learning
which is something we specialize in at
deepmind
um and reinforcement learning is about a
system that learns from first principles
through a process of trial and error
so if you see this sort of diagram here
if you think about
an agent uh or the ai system on the
left-hand side finds itself in some kind
of environment you know that environment
could be a a real environment in which
case uh the agent's probably some sort
of robot or it can be a simulated
environment uh like a game in which case
the agent is a kind of avatar virtual
avatar
and the agent gets observations about
the environment from its sensory
apparatus right so usually that's vision
but it can be other modalities as well
and the agent has some sort of goal
usually specified by the designers which
is trying to achieve in the context of
that environment
and in this kind of setup the agent's
got two jobs one is it's got to build a
model of the environment and the front
and the sort of state space and the
transitions in the environment uh based
on the observations so it's gonna
obviously be quite the the observation's
gonna be incomplete they're gonna be
noisy and somehow uh the agent has to
from that sort of noisy data has to
build a model of the environment now
once it has a model of the environment
it can use it to
make decisions about what it should do
next what actions should it take from
the set of actions available to it at
that moment
that will best get it towards its goal
incrementally towards its goal
and obviously um once the agent has run
out of thinking time it it outputs that
action executes the action that drives a
change in the environment which drives a
new observation and then the agent needs
to update its model based on that new
observation so in fact the agent here is
um an active participant in its own
learning uh and its own data gathering
so it's a little bit like a you know how
a scientist might work
so that's the reinforcement learning
setup it's very simple to explain and
show but it's uh you know the
complexities underlying this if you
really want to generalize this to
artificial general intelligences are
huge um in both the model building
aspects and the action choosing aspects
and also including the goal
specification all of those things are
pretty complex topics in themselves
but we know this works because um this
is how uh
the brain works and and um primate
brains use very informal reinforcement
learning temporal difference learning uh
in order to uh learn about their
environments
so we know in the limit that this should
be uh possible
this should be enough
um to drive artificial general
intelligence
now the most famous example uh sort of
prominent example of this working at
scale this type of reinforcement
learning system uh is as venky mentioned
alphago which was our program about five
years ago now to beat the world champion
uh at the game of go
now this is the game of go uh for those
who don't know it's uh amazing games
3000 years old
it's what they play in asia in china
japan korea instead of
chess sort of occupies that intellectual
echelon but it's actually much more
complex than chess
and
and it's much more about pattern
matching than chesses which is more
about calculation
and this is the reason why go has been
so hard for computers to play um so you
can think of chess was sort of solved
well not sold but cracked uh in the mid
90s you know when when deep blue beat
kasparov with these sort of uh massive
uh rules based uh expert systems but
that type of approach has never worked
with go um you can't even be a
professional player let alone a world
champion even 20 years off the deep blue
with that type of expert system approach
and the reason is twofold one is that um
the search space is absolutely enormous
in go so there are 10 to 170 possible
positions in go on the 19 by 19 board
which is more than the atoms in the
universe so obviously some kind of brute
force approach is not going to work not
going to scale
and the other thing is probably even
harder is the fact that it's impossible
to or proven to be impossible very
difficult to write down an evaluation
function an evaluation function that
will tell the system whether a position
is good or not good um and uh and and
how to rate a certain position and
obviously that's critical in allowing
the the the ai system to decide what to
do which move to choose
um and because go so esoteric
unlike chess which relies on material
and other things it's actually very
difficult to encapsulate um uh the the
the the dynamics of the game as a set of
rules
and so one might think well how do the
top human players deal with this
complexity well actually you know if you
talk to the top go players in the world
they tell you about a move felt right or
it looked right so they use this sort of
they use their intuition they rely
heavily on their intuition and pattern
matching rather than calculation often
if you ask a chess grandmaster why did
they make a particular move they'll have
an explicit plan they can tell you that
they were after um in go it's much uh
it's very different from that it's much
more intuitive
and that's not a word that we normally
associate with computers this kind of
intuitive capability
so what we did instead is instead of
trying to write down an evaluation
function a set of rules to allow
the computer to evaluate a position we
instead learnt one we got alphago to
learn for itself what was good about
positions
and learn for itself about go
so how did we do that well we trained a
neural network
to play against itself millions of times
and to learn through that process of
self-play how to evaluate position and
also how to pick um probable likely
moves to look at
in the current position
and the way we did that is
if you if this is a post incremental
process so if you imagine the version
one of alphago um maybe plays tens of
thousands of games against itself starts
off completely randomly um uh playing
completely randomly
that generates a set of data so you can
think of all those games that's played
as as data
and then it we train a second version of
the neural network version two
which is
learning things from that data set like
how to predict who the winner is going
to be from a certain position
and what sorts of moves are played in
certain positions
and then what we do is we have a little
mini tournament where the version two
plays the version one in a kind of like
a hundred game match-off and if it wins
55 of the time kind of a threshold rate
we replace v1 with this version two
uh of the system
if it loses or it doesn't across this 55
win threshold we carry on generating
more data with the v1 version right and
then we have 200 000 games to which to
train a new version to and then it tries
again to be version one so at some point
version two does beat version one then
we replace the the master system it is
now version two that now generates a new
set of data so if that plays against
itself a hundred thousand times a new
higher quality data set that's then used
to train version three which in turn
plays against version two and so on and
so forth and after about 17 18 uh
generations of this uh you get to world
champion level just from bootstrapping
from random play
so
um so this is the kind of you can think
of this as building the model about the
environment in this case um go
and now what we can do with that is
combine that model than your network
with the type of search function in this
case for go we use monte carlo tree
search so if you imagine this is the
tree of all possibilities from a go
position you know
10 to 170 possible positions obviously a
branching factor of like you know a 100
or so per move so this tree gets quickly
gets massive and what we what that what
the neural network does is it guides the
tree search so that it doesn't have to
consider all possibilities to obviously
be intractable but just the most
probable most valuable ones
so you can think of what the neural
network does the model is it limits the
search to just like maybe these blue um
paths right a fraction actually of the
total space and actually
much less than than the traditional
expert systems uh uh uh generally look
through so orders of magnitude less
positions so it's a little bit more like
how a human player would would uh
evaluate a position
and then finally uh it can then uh use
the tree search to then figure out
what's the best path out of those
probable paths those promising paths
which is here in pick
so we then went on um to have this sort
of famous million dollar challenge match
with lisa doll he's the 18 time world
champion and the sort of legend of the
game considered one of the greatest
players of all time
and um we played it in seoul the whole
of korea sort of came to standstill 200
million viewers and alphago 141
and um
this was sort of proclaimed to be a
decade before its time by both the go
fraternity and the ai
fraternity so both were pretty shocked
by this turn of events and um but it
wasn't so much just that alphago won the
match it was also how it won and in fact
it turned out that alphago came up with
original strategies that have never been
thought
by by human players before even though
this has been played for thousands of
years uh and professionally for hundreds
of years and this most famously happened
in game two of this five game match and
it's move 37 which has now gone down in
go um legend and has been sort of
studied
ever since the match uh and it's this
move here on the right-hand side which i
won't go into the reasons why this was
such a crazy unthinkable move but it's
basically this is an early part of the
game and you're not supposed to play on
the fifth line it's sort of unthinkable
to do that in this kind of position and
that's what alphago did and turns out
100 moves later
that stone
that move 37 was in exactly the right
place to win alphago the match um almost
as if it presidently had sort of put it
there
so um so this has sort of been studied
and
if you're interested in that and about
alphago i can recommend the document
this award-winning documentary about it
which talks through the whole story of
how the go world reacted to this and and
the new ideas that came about because of
that
so that's games and as venky was
alluding to and guess correctly the
reason we work on games initially at
deepmind we still do now is that they
are the perfect training ground for ai
methods and developing them and testing
them really efficient to use you can
simulate
millions of these game simulations in
parallel on cloud
and they're very convenient because they
usually have a very easily specifiable
goal right to win the game or to
maximize the points something like that
so it's quite easy to um to
generate the right test conditions uh
for ai
so um but that's of course not the
purpose of what we're doing at
deepminders games are fun i love games
i've worked them my whole life but
they're just a means to an end in the
sense of like we once we had developed
what we thought were general enough and
powerful enough learning algorithms then
we wanted to apply them to real world
problems to uh to grand challenges and
um and especially in the area of science
which is my personal passion and why
i've worked on ai my whole life
and so what's really amazing now is
finally after a decade of um
hard work and development i think we're
ready now to see a flourishing of
applications of these types of ai
systems to scientific discovery itself
so what do we look for in a problem and
this is half the battle as you all know
a scientist is picking the right
question um so how do we go about that
at deepmind well and i'm continually on
the lookout for these types of problems
that fit uh these criteria um so first
of all we we love uh problems that have
massive combinatorial search spaces or
state spaces and the reason we love that
is because um that what that means is
that exhaustive brute force methods more
kind of brute force methods won't work
right they just won't be tractable in
that kind of situation secondly we look
for problems that have clear objective
functions or clear metrics that we can
optimize against
that's very important for our learning
systems to have something to optimize
against and then third we either need
quite a lot of data or and or
an accurate and efficient simulator
because we have a simulator even if it's
noisy sometimes there's some signal in
that we can generate more data ourselves
um using compute so if those three
things hold usually that is a suitable
problem for
our
techniques learning techniques ai
techniques and surprisingly turns out
when you start looking for things with
this lens there are lots of problems um
in science and and also other real world
applications that actually fit uh fit
these criteria
um the one obviously i'm gonna talk
about today is is protein folding um
which actually takes all of those boxes
um very well and and and hence was one
of the first things we we turned our
attention to uh straight after alphago
um of course as you all know that
protein folding problem is is the
problem of going from an amino acid
sequence you can think of as like a one
dimensional array string array of uh
letters into uh the 3d protein structure
how can we go from this 1d structure and
predict the 3d structure from it
of course as as you'll be aware as well
that anthony is famously in 1972 is in
nobel prize lecture um sort of
conjectured that the three-dimensional
structure of a native protein should be
fully determinable by the amino acid
sequence
so this sort of set off then a 50-year
grand challenge in biology to see if
this was possible to do
of course
opposed against that was was levantal
and his his sort of paradox that he he
he mentioned which is that you know he
calculated that for an average protein
there might be something like 10 to the
300 possible confirmations so obviously
if you were to sort of exhaustively try
to sample this say one per second that
would be totally intractable longer than
you know the age of the universe and so
but yet this is the paradox obviously
nature and physics um for somehow folds
these proteins spontaneously often
within milliseconds so the big question
then is
can the protein structure prediction
problem be solved computationally in a
tractable way
so my particular journey on this
actually started long before even
deepmind
so i first came across the poem as an
undergrad actually um you know here at
cambridge at queen's
funny story because
the person who told me about this is
actually in the audience today tim
stevens who's actually at the lmb um he
was in my year at queen's and um and he
was obsessed with that problem even back
then and uh
at least as i remember it used to tell
everyone every available moment in the
bars about how important and
foundational this problem was and sort
of stuck with me actually for a long
time
and i kind of filed that away and then
later on
about 10 15 years later
i came across this again when i was
doing my postdoc at mit
when i came across the folded gate and
of course the foldit uh is a citizen
science game probably still one of the
best examples of that of getting
amateurs gamers really to try and um
fold proteins and turning it into a kind
of fun puzzle game and uh this of course
has caught my interest with my
background in games and science and i
still think it's fascinating idea this
idea of citizen science people playing
games but actually it turns out they're
doing something useful for science um
and what was intriguing was that the
best players were able to fold real
structures and i think there was a
couple of quite famous i think even a
nature paper where um some players did
find some new structure using the game
and that was another important piece of
the puzzle because i thought well that's
interesting that um you know they used
to bend the backbone as like a move and
things like that and sometimes they
would have to do counter-intuitive moves
uh at least from an energetic
perspective to actually get to the right
confirmation
so somehow these amateur
biologists i guess professional gamers
maybe they were um were able to use
their intuition to
pick the right move so to speak
and that made me think as we started
solving go you know perhaps this is
somewhat analogous to the intuition that
the go masters were using and telling me
about the way that they picked the moves
they were going to move
for in the middle of a go game
so we were able to mimic the go players
um with alphago why could we not mimic
um these folded players in tuition two
so that was one aspect that made me
think this was tractable
and then the other important piece of
the puzzle was was casp uh which is the
competition that's run every two years
um
since 1994. it's regarded as the gold
standard
for protein folding and it's really
important actually when you go after a
problem that there are these external
independent benchmarks that you can
benchmark your internal progress against
um obviously in games you can test it
against the best human players in the
world to see where you're at
and in casp there's this amazing
competition
that is a blind prediction assessment so
you know you get usually about 100
proteins for each competition but those
structures are not known that's the
critical thing they are not they have
not been published yet they're not known
at the time of the test they're only
revealed after the competition ends so
there's no way you can sort of over fit
or anything else to these
structures even by accident and i just
want to give a shout out to john malt
and who's the founder of this and the
cast organizers who've been running this
for you know for so many years now
nearly three decades and they do an
incredible job of that and it's an
amazingly well-run competition and i
actually think this kind of
external benchmark could be very useful
in other uh areas of science if it was
to be replicated
so what's been what has had happened at
casp historically well actually if you
see from this bar here for the sort of
the the decade between 2006 and 2016
there hadn't been a lot of progress
progress was pretty limited and um uh
the the this is the this is the um the
gdt score uh for the hardest category
the free modeling category um where
there's no templates and other things
and you can see the scores more or less
um
has not improved very much i mean
the competition has got harder over each
year so there's been a little bit of
improvement but not a huge amount
um and then what we happened is we came
uh sort of along in 2018 for the cast 13
competition was the first one we entered
and um
i think we were the first to sort of
introduce the use of ml as the core
component and at scale and um this you
know alpha fold one won the competition
um by quite a large margin and we
improved accuracies on the on the
hardest category here free modeling by
by close to 50 percent so it was a
really big jump in um performance
and if you want to you know if you're
interested in the the details of that
particular system uh you can check out
our paper from 2020 that describes that
in detail
then for the months afterwards we tried
to push this system further but we sort
of reached the ceiling of the
performance and we realized that we
needed to go back to the drawing board
take the knowledge and the know-how we'd
learned from alpha 4.1 and and complete
but completely re-architect uh the
system uh and that's what we entered as
alpha fall 2 in the cast 14 competition
last year last summer between the 2020
edition and that then finally reached
this um threshold of atomic accuracy
so these are the results uh uh from 20
to from the 2020 competition from cast
14. um the magic threshold that we were
told by john mull and others of the
organizers was less than one angstrom
error uh you know more or less the width
of an atom and that was the key
threshold that uh was felt to be
competitive with experimental methods
and therefore would maybe be useful in
practice uh a widely used practice
and alpha fold two achieved a 0.96
angstrom error
and was around three times better than
the next best system in cast 14 uh even
though obviously those systems were
incorporating our ideas from the cast 13
competition
so it was again by a very large margin
and and the new changes that we'd
introduced
here's some example predictions
really uh interesting proteins that
we're getting over 90 gdp score on uh
and even as you see on the left hand
side there the from the size covid uh
the side chains often uh as well in in
in the correct positions or very nearly
the correct positions
now um this is the iphone 2 fold to
architecture it's pretty complex
architecture i'm not going to go into it
today because john is going to cover
that in more detail in his talk so i'll
leave that to him
um but the key advances that are worth
thinking about is
and sort of noting this is probably the
most complex system we have ever built
and we built some pretty complicated
systems of d mind and um one measure of
that is like there's 32 component
algorithms um in the in the in the
methods paper there's 60 pages of si
supplementary information was just an
indication of the complexity involved
and what i would say is there was no
sort of single silver bullet but
actually a host of insights and
innovations were needed and then
carefully and sort of cleverly
integrated together in order to crack
this problem
and the three main things that were uh
sort of advances over the cast 13 system
was firstly this was an end-to-end
system uh with an iterative recycling
stage that allowed the the structure to
sort of be refined with each stage um
alpha fold one was not end to end
produced a distagram and then we had to
have a gradient descent module that
actually created the structure and what
we found in machine learning is the more
end to end you can make things the
better and let it directly optimize that
what you're actually after in this case
the structure
we changed from convolutional neural
networks to a tension-based neural
network that that then inferred the
implicit graph structure of the between
the residues and then probably the most
key thing was how to build in
evolutionary and physics constraints
things about the local geometry for
example into the architecture the neural
network architecture but without
impacting the learning and that's a real
challenge in machine learning it's how
to bring to bear prior knowledge that
you have about domain but
and and bringing those constraints in a
useful way that doesn't end up impacting
and holding back the learning
so another thing to note about is that
this has been actually probably our
biggest research effort so far it's
taken over five years you know roughly
about 20 people
and it needed a very multidisciplinary
team so of course we have machine
learning and engineering but actually
biologists chemists and physicists um
all in the mix here to actually um solve
this problem
and then maybe one final point to make
is usually at deepmind when we're
working on machine learning we're very
interested in the idea of generality
right so when we're making building
testing our systems on games we don't
want to over fit to that game itself we
we want to build systems that are very
general so for example with the alphago
uh system i showed you we ended up
developing that into alpha zero which
could play any two player game um and it
didn't need any human data so it it was
to play go and chess and japanese chess
and so on and um one system was able to
do that and that's what we're after with
because we're after building artificial
general intelligence but when you're
trying to solve an applied problem uh an
app which which has uh use in of itself
like alpha fold downstream use then
actually uh what we what we do there is
take all of our know-how and throw
everything we have at it including
domain knowledge right it's no holes bar
like we're not going to just limit
ourselves to general purpose systems and
general
techniques that can can generalize to
other areas we actually just care about
solving this problem with everything
we've got so we really through
everything we had uh all i know all of
our ideas um at this problem and
generality is sort of secondary having
said that we will go back generally you
know what we do is ai is a sort of i
call it an engineering science because
before you can inspect it scientifically
you have to build it first the artifact
first so unlike a natural science where
the phenomena already exists you have to
actually build it first so what we found
is the best way to get to generality is
to solve the problem first like with
alphago and then take asp take modules
out and see what was actually necessary
for the performance and then that way
you get a more
general system so that's still to come
for things like alpha folders to see
what what aspects of that were needed
and john again we'll talk about that um
in his talk
so another thing i want to mention is
about speed and scale so um
again the way we try to to tackle these
problems is focus first on performance
can you actually crack the problem in
this case get to an error of less than
one angstrom
and then afterwards once you've reached
that threshold then you worry about
optimizing your system and making it as
efficient as possible so alpha volt2 now
is you know extremely fast it uses a
very moderate amount of compute
by modern machine learning standards so
training takes about two weeks on eight
tpu chips
which is equivalent to 150 gpus
and so this isn't really a story about
massive compute um it's it's actually
was the algorithmic advances that were
the critical things here
and then the inference so actually
coming up with the structure is
extremely fast so it now takes you know
order of minutes for an average size
protein on a single gpu
um so when we started seeing these
speeds you know around late last year um
we were starting to think about also how
would we um how would we give broad
access to these predictions what would
be the right way to do that uh for the
research community for all of you to use
and um you know the traditional way in
this field is to
say maybe stand up a server and then you
know you could submit your sequence
you're issued in and then we give you
back um the server would give you back
that structure but what we realized we
did back of envelope calculations on
this is that we could that the entire
proteomes now were within reach and so
rather than setting up a server and a
service we should just fold everything
um and and and then put it out there for
everyone to to use
so that's when we started thinking about
proteome scale things and and then
starting with the human proteome so the
first thing we did was run that
we did the first version of that i think
over christmas when um a lot of the
machines were
available and we did the 20 000 uh
proteins one of the things i love about
ai is that while you're having your
christmas lunch it can be doing work for
you um i've always thought that's
fascinating about computers and machines
and ai specifically so all the 20 000
proteins are expressed by the human
genome experimental coverage as all of
you will know is about was about 17
and then we more than doubled that to 36
with very high accuracy confidence uh
and 58 at what we would call high
accuracy um and including some
interesting insights into proteins that
um
may be unstructured in isolation uh or
disordered and and john will talk a
little bit more about that uh disordered
uh proteins in his talk
so we think this is the sort of most
complete and accurate picture of the of
the human proteome ever
now what do i mean by those means what i
just mentioned by very high accuracy and
high accuracy or one of the important
things about this model that was
critical for this model is an output of
its own confidence in its predictions so
measures of uncertainty are um not that
common i would say machine learning
models they're sort of like a nice to
have like everyone talks about them and
they would be good if they generated
them um but a lot of people a lot of
machine animals don't do that um but we
thought it was critical here actually uh
given that we wanted this to be used
downstream and relied upon by
experimental biologists it was important
for them to be able to interpret the
results in some sort of simple way like
which aspects of these predictions could
be relied on and and and um and and and
then therefore how they should interpret
to their experiments they're going to
build on top of that
so we felt this was not a nice to have
in this case it was an essential and so
what we went ahead and did was
we trained after fault to in addition to
producing the structures to also output
a per residue confidence metric uh which
we call p p l d d t and they're sort of
three thresholds that are relevant here
um
the the above 90 we consider to be very
high accuracy and what that means is
that the side chains we believe are
quite reliable as well and um
potentially it's sort of comparable or
competitive with experiment
um
the next threshold down which we call
high accuracy is sort of greater than
70. we color in this sort of light blue
so dark blue is over 90 light blue is
over 70. and there what we would say is
that the backbone is probably reliable
so um
and so that's could still be of use uh
for some applications
and then interestingly um below 50 you
know we sort of say it's a very low
confidence uh prediction and it turns
out the early early
sort of evidence suggests that this may
actually be a good predictive disorder
or unstructured in isolation so it may
actually be telling us something about
the underlying biology
we didn't make a strong claim in this in
the papers because it was very early
days we just sort of
kind of did some basic analysis on it
and it looked like it was um
trending in the right direction but
since we've released the papers we've
had some um people experts in disorder
contact us and it seems to be holding up
so more research is needed and we're
doing some collaborations on this to see
if this is um how reliable this is um
but it certainly seems uh promising that
it could be
a thought of a disorder predictor
so uh we didn't just stop a human
protein we thought we might as well fold
another 20 uh model organisms and uh
proteomes uh we tried to choose ones
that were you know be maximally useful
to the research community so a bunch of
model organisms things like fruit fly e
coli the mouse c elegans zebrafish and
so on and yeast um other research
species pathogens
uh like malaria and so on and then some
crop species as well uh made it into the
top 20 and obviously we are in the
process of um expanding that
and then we thought about the
accessibility of this so we had all
these proteomes how are we gonna sort of
structure these databases and um we've
had a wonderful collaboration with uh
the european bioinformatics institute uh
just around the corner emblem epi who
you know the leading world's leading
experts in providing databases for the
scientific community and uh we thought
rather than creating our own thing we
should just plug into the main vein of
uh biological tools
and then um and build this database with
them
and their expertise and tooling and how
to how to do this in the right way um
and that scientists will be used to uh
already in their workflow and provide a
free and unrestricted access to every
structure uh for any use uh case and
that along with us open sourcing all the
code um
we felt was the in this case the best
way to maximize the scientific impact
and benefit to the to the research
community and it's been really uh
heartening to get all the feedback from
experimenters about how this has been
useful to them and even today in lunch
and other meetings hearing how you're
all using alpha fold and i'd love to
hear more stories about um how that's
helping you in your work
so then finally you know what what are
we planning next
um well over the next year we plan to
fold every protein or almost every
protein let's say in uniprot so it's
going to be over 100 million proteins um
it's a big job uh also to quality
control that so we're sort of scaling
even our scaled up version to to attempt
to do this
but that's very exciting um and then
future work you know i'm very interested
in uh we're sort of branching in protein
complexes disorder proteins point
mutations
ligand docking and protein design and
that's just a sample of many of these
projects we're already working on some
we're just starting up
with collaborations
and uh actually uh john's gonna talk
about a couple of these uh a lot more in
his talk
so um
overall what we're trying to do is you
know of course we've done
we've done sort of static structure
prediction here uh with alpha fall 2 and
that's great and really useful hopefully
but we want to eventually work our way
towards understanding function
and trying to do as much of that
computation as possible and some of
these things will help us get towards
that and understanding the dynamics and
the physics of uh what's going on uh
with proteins
so i just want to end by maybe a couple
of more philosophical ideas um if you
like i think when i the more i've looked
into um biology the last few years
especially obviously with the whole
alpha fall project um i've always been
fascinated by biology and i think at its
most fundamental level it's the way i
think about it it's an information
processing system albeit an organic one
um and i think that that there's a lot
of kind of isomorphisms between between
those two things like information
processing and computer science and
biology in that respect
um but the thing is obviously life is
phenomenally complex an emergent process
um sort of the emergent property of
countless interactions tons of weak
signals um so i think it's sort of too
complex actually to describe purely
mathematically you know what one of the
ways i say that is sort of you know is
there going to be the equivalent of
newton's laws of motion for for a cell i
find that hard to believe because it's
just so such such a complex interactive
system
um but i think that ai
might be the perfect sort of tool to
understand that kind of regime um it's a
sort of perfect regime for iai in many
ways and i think of it as just like
maths is um the sort of right
description language for physics i think
ai might turn out to be just the right
level of description language for
biology and i think alpha fold
i hope is a sort of first proof of
concept of that and you know maybe sort
of heralds the beginning of a new era of
what i'm calling sort of digital biology
and um you know the dream at some point
maybe would be to scale up to one day
something like a virtual cell
and then just in terms of just to finish
off with my sort of the title of my talk
there are actually many other fields
that we're working in not as mature as
what we've done with alpha fold but some
we've had some major breakthroughs this
year on each of these fields quantum
chemistry pure mathematics uh medical
diagnosis material design and actually
some other topics too things like
weather forecasting um and they'll be
coming out later this year early next
year and um you know i really believe
that this uh it is a kind of a new a new
amazing tool for science and um can
impact all sorts of areas of science
that certainly that satisfy those three
criteria i mentioned in uh earlier in
the talk and and if you think of it that
way i think of ai it's a bit like the
hubble telescope for so for cosmologists
you know it allows them to see further
into the cosmos i see ai as a sort of
ultimate tool in a way to help us as
scientists see further into to our
domains
so i just want to end by thanking uh
the pdb and all of you who are
experimentalists experimental community
obviously um all the amazing work that's
been done here starting with john
kendrew and people like him um which we
couldn't have done without all of that
data we wouldn't have been able to build
alpha fold and i just want to thank
everyone who made alpha 4 possible both
the methods group and the human protein
group obviously there's there's quite a
few people overlapping in both of those
two groups um the wider team at deepmind
all of our machine learning expertise we
have around us at deepmind to help um
collaborators at mlubi the cass
community and the experimental college
community thanks for listening
well thank you very much uh that was
that was a fascinating talk
so um
let's we have a
few minutes for questions so i'll take a
couple questions so roger it's really
incredible
could you could you actually wait for
the microphone because otherwise the
online
audience won't be able to hear it's
really impressive what alpha
it's really impressive what it's
accomplished but
there are also some amazingly dumb
things um
when you look at predictions you can see
domains that you've known the structure
for 20 years they're completely
unreliably predicted i mean not even
close to what they actually are i mean
the simplest algorithm of saying is it
homologous to anything with a known
structure would have gotten it right and
your alpha fold is completely wrong
is do you have a way to learn from these
things yeah so we try and incorporate
templates and things like that into the
learning system and there's the inputs
it will happen from time to time i mean
it's a learning system so we're trying
to analyze ourselves like why it's doing
certain things and um
you can think of it i'll give you an
analogy with alphago when we got it to
be the world champions and everything
every now and again like in game four
the one that he won it would start sort
of evaluating positions wrongly and
sometimes they weren't even the most
complex position sometimes there'd be
some simple motif why can't it
understand that motif and you can think
of it as a bit like a bug but the
problem with these bugs is it's a bug in
its knowledge
so it's different from a normal bug in a
software system you go in and debug it
and add some new if then statement and
say oh look up the homolog right but if
you do that then you what about the
situations how does it balance that
against what it's learned right so that
that's the that's the difficulty and
also i mentioned about the constraints
we put in that's already quite hard
although it learns on top of that if you
do hard coded things like that it can
damage it in a different situation so
um
we'd love though to hear feedback from
review of things that like that that
it's not doing properly um and then we
would what we would generally do while
we were talking to various people at
lunch today about that is um the next
stage is to create a test set
of dumb things right and uh we used to
call it a shoot co test set for go
where there was like a initially 100
positions it turned out to be a thousand
positions where alpha alpha go in that
case would do really stupid things and
so what we asked the new versions of
alphago to do was not just beat their
own themselves previously on the normal
metrics winning the game and everything
but also they'd have to heal climb and
do better on that specific test set held
out test set and once we did that we got
to about 99 on those test positions we
it seemed to solve this sort of
knowledge gap so to speak so i think
we're going to need to do something like
that with alpha fold um and we we really
need the help of the experimental
community to do that because we're not
experts in all the different proteins
like you all are so we you know if you
see something that's
you know done like that please email it
to us i think there's a email on the on
the bottom of our database for feedback
and tell us look you do this this thing
you shouldn't do it here's the homolog
what it's doing and we'll put it in our
test set and then alpha fall three will
hopefully you know our next version will
hopefully have fixed a lot of those
problems um yeah
hey dennis um have any of your team
looked at using your models to bootstrap
uh full physics dynamic simulations of
proteins maybe sort of
using your confidence scores as
restraints somehow and letting the rest
float yeah we are um working on those
kinds of things now and sort of trying
to um that's the next phase and we need
a whole new type of system probably to
try and understand the physics of what's
going on versus just translate you know
the the sequence to the structure and um
we haven't got any you know results to
talk about yet but we're you know
there's some promising things we've got
to get back to using that physics uh
approach back to the level alpha fold is
and then from there we might see some
some improvements or at least extensions
of what these systems can do to the
dynamics and interactions and binding
affinities all of these things that are
you know you probably have to understand
a bit about physics or more about the
physics than alpha fold two implicitly
understands anyway yeah and actually it
would be nice to get an ensemble of
structural models out rather than just
that
yeah different confirmations and then if
something binds to them they change yeah
exactly where this is we're thinking
about all these misfolded proteins
almost like you want to say like
what's the most likely fold and then
some of the secondary you know folds
energetically these kinds of things um
yeah we're not able to do that yet but
we have to we have to go a bit further
with understanding the physics i think
to in order to do that properly
any more questions here okay
hey there much thanks very much um so
you said that your mission and
motivation was always
kind of to contribute to science uh and
um i was wondering if you could give us
the main reasons why you decided to like
very consciously decided to pursue that
in a commercial setting in the company
rather than trying to pursue an academic
career that could also have maybe
achieved these things and yeah i hope
the answer doesn't give too many
sleepless nights in this audience
yeah well look i
a deep mind is a is a hybrid
organization you know we try to
consciously blend the best from academia
and the kind of blue sky thinking
ambitious thinking we have in the best
places like best institutes like this
place and long-term thinking let's say
which often doesn't happen in companies
and then blend that with the best from
startups so the energy the pace and the
focus and the organization that the best
startups have and then we sort of
combine that with the third thing which
is alphabet resources and so that's one
of the reasons we teamed up with them is
we needed you know the compute power so
that not only to train individual
systems but also to do experiments for
us our workbench is
computers right that's how we try out
our ideas and get results and then
improve so um so all of those factors uh
made it
you know for me at least easier to do
that
in a commercial setting or
in theory i mean it's not it's not it's
not a normal commercial setting let's
put it that way we don't have we don't
have to worry about short-term
profitability things like that which
would really impact um
your long-term research programs i think
that's the thing that's what goes wrong
a lot with industrial research labs is
they get pulled around too short-term by
product requirements and i've always
tried to insulate deep mind from that
and uh and then you know you get things
like alpha fold and half ago if you're
patient enough
and you have the right set up so i just
think for this particular thing we
needed which was computers um that was
the right setup for that
but for other for other
big projects it may not be the case
but for us i think it accelerated us by
five past years
us combining with those resources and we
had we're not we're not idea constrained
right uh and then the other thing i'd
mention is in academia it's difficult to
get permanent positions for engineers
top level engineers not just scientists
and i think that's a perennial
structural problem with science like
what's the career path for the the top
engineers we actually created a whole
new job
kind of description called research
engineers that's a sort of combination
of amazing engineering jobs but also
um some research skills and that these
research engineers are sort of key to
scaling a lot of this stuff up and
making it work
um but i you know it's very difficult to
see how you would get that funded in
traditional lab models
we'll take a couple of questions from
the online viewers so one of them mark
durr asks
sorry chris boulder asks are there any
plans to apply deep mind approaches to
general problems and non-linear physics
like turbulence or shear flow
yes
um yeah we are actually exactly looking
at that um one of the things we're doing
we haven't really announced together but
maybe i can talk about it's like you
know looking at things like um
plasma containment fusion reactors so
these are
for sure i think ai systems are going to
be right for that there's also like
predicting the weather which is very
nearly a physics system uh like the
rainfall we just published a paper on
that which is the most accurate
prediction of rainfall in the next two
hours um which is quite relevant for the
uk and we we did that with the met
office and it's better than any of their
obviously very sophisticated weather
models they have uh and i feel that we
can scale that up maybe to you know
climate models and other things so i
think that's a very fruitful area
actually
then there's a question from
felix dingler from the mrc whim at
oxford
[Music]
which says you mentioned the input of
subject matter expertise but what about
output how much do you believe we have
to enjoy ai on the strength of its
performance as a dsx machina
are there human
uh interpretable lessons on protein
folding that you can clean so i think
there's a general problem yes that ai is
a black box and how do you learn yeah uh
principles so i think it's sort of
twofold that question i kind of touched
on in my talk which was that if you if
the outputs in themselves are really
useful
then
you know that that make use of that
um and i think you know that's that's
that's totally uh valuable in itself so
i would say that's the case without a
fold i mean imagine you you found a cure
for cancer um i don't think you'd be
quibbling about how the machine
necessarily came up with that idea you
would just we would just use it in
medicine
on the other hand if we want to look we
also of course the scientists were
interested in mechanisms and underlying
mechanisms so we are uh currently
working we have a whole research group
that works on analytic tools to kind of
break down um what these systems are
doing uh actually john's gonna talk
about what we mentioned our methods
paper about all the ablation we did a
very careful ablation studies that took
play every part of the system and see
what mattered turns out all of it
mattered um
sort of cutting to the point but to
different degrees and then the other
thing we'd like to understand is the
representations they build and these
intermediate representations what do
they what do they actually represent in
the real world domain and um i would say
that the
the analytic tool community is quite
nascent relative to the performance
engineering and i think that's it's
obviously going to lag by five years or
so because you've got to build
impressive systems that are worth even
studying and taking apart and then it
takes several years to understand that
system in the same way you would have to
it takes years to understand any natural
phenomena they're just as complex these
artificial systems as biological systems
um perhaps we're in a slightly easier
range because they're digital so we can
pull them apart more more easily um but
yeah we're going to have to cover new
analysis techniques i think to to look
inside these black boxes
okay since
it's
3 30 it's time for our break so thank
you very much